So we're using these token definitions in regular expressions
to break down HTML and JavaScript into important words.
As we've seen before, there can be lots of extra space
between various tokens.
We really want to skip or pass over spaces
and possibly newline characters and tabs.
More on that later.
We do that using the same sort of token definition as before,
so here I've made a regular expression that just matches a single space,
but instead of returning the token, we pass it by.
This is the power.
Let's test out our knowledge with a quiz.
We've already seen how to do left and right angle bracket sorts of tokens.
We've taken a look at strings before.
And now let's do words, which are almost everything else on a web page.
Let's say that we want a word to be any number of characters
except a left angle bracket, a right angle bracket,
or a space, and here I really mean the single character
pressing the space bar, not this 5-character word, but it's hard to write out.
And when you're writing your function to match word tokens,
you should leave the value unchanged.
Submit a definition for t_word using the interpreter.